[Music]
[Applause]
is building a complete crypto payments
ecosystem
for the united arab emirates and
decentralizing a 414
billion dollar economy
[Music]
hey guys and welcome back to the layout
heil pen show powered by
icon plus so since it's powered by
openplus as usual i'm going to give a
really quick news announcement for you
so
korea's the largest mobile payment
provider denial fintech is now joining
the icon ecosystem as a p
rep so now fintech will integrate the
icx token into its global payments app
so as always
brilliant news coming from icon i also
want to say a quick thank you to my
sponsors blockfi
so i actually use them to earn up to 8.6
interest on my usdc so if you don't know
that's a stable coin
so we totally recommend signing up
because at the moment you can actually
get
i think it's up to 250 dollars if you
sign up with them and deposit x amount
of money so
that's great totally recommend them and
before we jump in
i also want to give a huge shout out to
coin flip so coin flip they're doing
some incredible work across the states
to push bitcoin mass adoption so they
have
45 atms across the states and if you use
my discount code which i'll put in there
in the comments you can get 10 off all
transactions so that's great
moving on with our show i have a really
exciting yesterday somebody who
is a bit of an inspiration somebody
who's always providing incredible crypto
content amazing trading analysis
somebody who is a mum it is of course
crypto wendy how are you doing i'm good
thanks for having me and thank you for
the kind words i appreciate it
of course it's such a pleasure so for
those that don't know i've been trying
to
chat with you for a while we've had a
few conversations here and there but we
haven't been able to fully
sort of just like get to know each other
so i want to kind of just take this as
an opportunity to
understand a little bit more about you
your road into crypto and how it all
started
okay so i actually first heard about
bitcoin in 20 like 2011 20
2012 i had a family member living with
me he's like can we borrow your credit
card to buy
um to buy bitcoin because i have to buy
something online i was like no
i had no idea what it was it was in kind
of a traditional or
a transitional part of my life because i
was just kind of getting on my feet or
just kind of i was in school to
to go work in health care and i didn't
have money back then at all
at all it was just so i didn't really
think about it and i also the way i was
brought up i never thought okay tech was
something for me something that i can
work in because
my mom had three kids she was a single
mom my dad passed away young and it was
just kind of like you're going to get up
you're going to go to school every day
and you're going to go to college and
that's it and it wasn't really like
there wasn't really any guidance
it was just kind of we were kind of on
our own and then i was in my job
at healthcare i worked in infectious
disease hiv aids for seven years
at the largest um hiv aids place
globally we service i think they service
about 500 000 patients now
which is amazing but i was getting tired
of that job because
um big corporate structure i'm not into
big corporate structure
um they of course they want you when you
work in healthcare in the united states
they want you to put a lot of hours and
a lot of time and they don't give raises
and i was getting really tired of it i
was in school and then i
was gonna quit my job my daughter was
brand new i kept hearing about bitcoin
on like libertarian radio
and i was like okay this is something i
should probably i should probably look
into because i wanted to learn how to
trade but i wasn't sure where to start
so i remember i bought my first part of
a bitcoin and from there
i just kind of i saw all these people
posting on twitter
like these charts and i was like this is
really cool
if they could do it i can do it because
i have that mindset that i can do
anything i set my mind to i started to
not be
really negative i started to not be
pessimistic and change that mindset
so i started i taught myself how to
train and i started posting content on
twitter
and then started hosting events and then
from there all these really amazing
opportunities came
so many questions from that so i don't
know where to go with this okay so
let's go let's i want to pick you up and
when you said you sort of changed your
mindset
you thought you'd be a bit more positive
about something so tell me more about
that what do you mean why was there such
a negative mindset and how did you
make that shift because a lot of people
are always sort of stuck in a certain
sort of negative mental cycle i mean i
for one can often get into absolute
negative cycles and
you know you need something to sort of
like kick you so what was that about
it's so my life was um again like my i
was raised with
a single mom my dad passed away when i
was 11. my life was not
i got bullied a lot in school because i
was different i was very outspoken
and it really fit in with a lot of the
girls because it was just a lot of
pettiness and stuff like that
i always had like male friends um so i
got it i ended up getting in like
um a lot of not not like a lot of
trouble like not like where i was
gaffled up or anything but i just
started going down the wrong
path because of depression and just
being like just being miserable and just
thinking okay my life is meaningless
so it's very negative for a long time
and i didn't realize
that when you have this negative aspect
when you're looking at life
if you're negative about everything even
though it is bad
then it makes it even worse so the
minute you start to change it around and
you're like okay let me look at this in
a positive aspect and let me be thankful
for
for small things i have like i have
mobility in my hands i could walk
i have two eyes i've got two ears just
something that
simple and if you start to retrain your
brain that's what happened so i started
just to be more positive and even though
when i quit my job i had no idea what i
was going to do with my life
i just knew i was going to go to school
and it was going to work out i used to
never be that way i was always very
planned out
and then once i once i started changing
that my life started to get better
and how did how did you how did you
change that because somebody told me
i'll just
tell you a quick story someone told me a
story the other day that they were at a
bus stop
and um everybody there everybody was
doing their commute to work
and everybody looked very miserable
except for one man sitting in a
wheelchair
he was having the best time laughing and
i think that story is super powerful
because
you know like you said we are
able-bodied and a lot of the time we
sort of don't appreciate that and we
take it absolutely for granted
um until suddenly you don't have that
and you sort of wish you took it for
granted you know
didn't take it for granted you
appreciated it so what i did in this
town so this is probably going to sound
crazy to people but i just i was like
there was like a like a year period was
like i have to make a positive change
because i was just so miserable my job i
loved my patients i loved my clients
i loved helping people that's what i did
i really really helped people i managed
their care
i spent a lot of time with my patients
and i was just so miserable because
there was no raises in healthcare like i
never got a raise and that's like very
depressing when you're working so hard
and you're commuting i would i worked
410 hour shifts a week and i commuted
three hours round trip
but i got the i went i went next door
because i
yeah it was crazy i did this for seven
years i went next door to the thrift
store
i got the secret book and i just kept it
in my car with me and i would force
myself to read like a page every day
like before work
and i know it sounds lame but just that
little bit of positivity even just
having that book next to me
that really kind of helped me be like
okay just look at just be thankful that
you have a job be thankful that you have
money because there was a time where i
was homeless there was a time when i
didn't have money
when i was struggling when i was worried
about all these different things
and that wasn't the case i had a job and
i had a roof over my head
yeah that's cool that you mentioned the
secret i've read it the secret is kind
of like what i live my life by and it is
hard it is so hard to sort of keep up
the um the positivity and so on but i
find like it's the only answer though
isn't it because
you're not going to get where you want
to be if you sort of stay that miserable
but you said that you taught yourself to
trade that's insane how did you do that
so i bought um i bought two books on
ebay they were used because i'm a i'm an
avid thrift store shopper
um and it was like i think it was a the
technical technical analysis for idiots
and the candlestick um candlestick for
dummies
and i just read those every night i had
my daughter was still really young then
i think she was like about a year
um so i would just on my breaks i would
take 10 minutes and i would read
at work and then 10 minutes before i
went to sleep i would cut out netflix
and i would just read and i would
highlight stuff and then i got a trading
view account because trading view is
free or you guys can go to coin trader
pro they're free as well or chart ex
and you just start drawing lines on a
chart and just start paper trading and
so that's what i did and so i was doing
pretty good with all coins
um because all coins are where you would
make you could make more money trading
all coins in bitcoin
and i just kept i just kept at it and i
think a big part of that was having a
strong background in math because at one
time i wanted to be a pharmacist so i
had to take all these stem classes
and i just remember doing taking
calculus and having to do derivatives
over and over and over again and the
same for
trick or not trick but for chem and with
training it's all about repetition
yeah you need to have some form of gosh
you know background or intellect in that
kind of area or whatever it is you know
it you have to be able to
in order to sort of like apply yourself
when it comes to all of these things
i will disagree with you on that and the
reason being
you can have you can have having a
strong math background is great and it
does help but you don't have to like if
you're watching this you're like oh my
god i want to learn to trade but i don't
have a strong back
math background it's a different type of
math yes a lot of the indicators that we
use they are math-backed
but at the end of the day if you can
kind of spot patterns if you're good at
seeing patterns
and you know how to control your
emotions if you can control your
emotions but you're not good at spotting
patterns you're gonna out trade most of
the traders because we
me personally when i'm feeling emotional
or my daughter's like coming in like
mommy this mommy that i could i feel
myself getting emotional i feel myself
getting frustrated so i take a step back
and there's a lot of trades i don't take
because i've got all this other stuff
going on
okay so one key thing that i'm always
hearing when it comes to trading then
is being in control of your emotions
that is like essential so what would you
say the top three things is
when people when you want to start
trading one of my favorite followers is
actually just commented saying that
there's
loads of courses now available online as
well so if there are that many courses
online and people are going to get into
this
what are the three top things people
need to know um do not trade if you're
feeling any type of emotions
if something's happened to you if you're
tired if you were hungry
just stay away from the charts if you're
hungry i love that surprise well no
it's it's true because it is we get
anything that impacts our emotion or
impacts our vibrations that we have and
we're just killing the feeling off stay
away
number two no taking no trade is or
no taking no trade is also an action and
it will it saved me quite a few times
because sometimes i'll look on twitter
i'm like oh my god everybody's making
money i'm not making money
and then i'll go ahead i'll follow in
and i'll enter a trade and then i get
wrecked and that's because i did not
because i should have sat out and i knew
i should have sat out so that's number
two
and then number three is really just
kind of taking
like taking a step back and analyzing
what's going on with the market
analyzing the sentiment because there's
a
and sometimes also too don't look at
twitter don't watch other traders
have a plan write it down and then if
and then execute that trade
and decide if it's the correct trade for
you don't go on twitter and don't go
look at what other people are doing
unless you have like a trading group but
if you're
going and you're basing your stuff off
other people you're going to get wrecked
because you don't know um the amount of
time and what these other people have
been putting into their trades you don't
know what their trading journal looks
like trading journal is really really
important
and when you actually write fit me
personally i like to physically write
stuff down so it holds me accountable
if you're just blindly entering into a
trade and you have no idea what you're
doing you're gonna get wrecked and you
don't buy
you do not buy green candles you buy red
candles yeah
never buy on green always on red but
that sort of takes me back to the summer
because
when the whole yield farming and d5
thing exploded
people were making so much money well so
they say on twitter
you know oh yeah just did this just did
that made this much money
but it's kind of it's not yes it's for
everyone but it's not for everyone
immediately if they don't know what
they're doing
essentially well the thing with the d5
is is a lot of people don't understand
how it works or how to use it
so when we're talking about i'm trading
d5 we're talking about trading all coins
there's a purpose for that um
yes alts can do a lot of different
things and we can talk about that later
on but if you're just specifically
um trading we want a trade to accumulate
more bitcoin or more fiat or whatever it
is
you get into your position you practice
very tight risk management
and you get out of your position i had
one of my subs comment on my video about
about a particular coin they're like oh
i invested 20 000
into this and it went to 500 and it's a
scam i was like it's not a scam i says
you just don't practice good risk
management when you're trading
when you're trading these all coins you
want to get in you want to get out
and you don't really want to look at it
again unless you're interested in
getting in again and then if you want
you keep a moon bag and a moon bag is
when you've
completely exited out of a trade um
you've recouped your capital
you've made a little bit on top and it's
you own it completely free and clear if
you want to go ahead and yield farm that
and put it in somewhere
and take a risk with it go ahead and do
that but don't invest 20 000
and put it into some yield farming and
then forget about it and expect this
thing to moon
because chances are it's probably not
going to
yeah i want to get into all of this
especially that whole scam
is it a scam is it not a scam i'm going
to get all of that but i want to talk
firstly about your
road to success because you have had a
tough life which you mentioned
um which means you probably had to make
a lot of tough decisions
and one of the key ones like you said is
sort of leaving that corporate world and
moving into crypto and crypto
is inherently you know unstable just
because it is such an immature market
so how was it so how has it been
literally you know leaving something
which is stable leaving something which
you know
um you have that predictable income
particularly as a mom you have
responsibilities
so how how has that been moving into
something which you know we don't know
where it's going to be in a year from
now in some ways it's sort of like a
gamble sort of gambling your career on
something
so when i first left my job it wasn't to
go into crypto full-time
because trading is always in and still
is kind of like a hobby to me at this at
this point but more so it's even more as
a hobby because i'm so busy doing all
this other stuff in the background and
that provides my main source of income
so i left school or excuse me i left my
old job to finish school
so i was able to get my degree even
though i do think majority of college is
a scam but at the end of the day in the
united states
at the end of the day in the united
states if you don't have a degree you're
not going to get a job
like it's just it's same in the uk it's
not going to happen and a lot of these
degrees are just
like i did not need a degree in business
and i did not need a degree in marketing
but i was able to cash flow that
um so my my thing was is i was going to
leave my old job i was going to get my
degree and i was going to go back in the
workforce but in the midst of that in
the middle
um i was able to do crypto full time and
make like an a good a decent income
doing that
um but as far as being successful i
still have a long way to go i'm not a
millionaire yet i want to be a
millionaire
and there's other things that i do want
to do in the space before i actually do
consider myself as successful
so what's the goal then um you said
a millionaire but realistically no i
don't mean realistically not a
millionaire i mean like what drives you
from the heart like what is the goal
what do you want to achieve for yourself
at this point it's just i want to
continue to grow and part of my
content that i do especially on youtube
it's really i
i keep it very i keep things very very
simple i keep things very honest i'm not
very silly i'm not like oh my god
you know like we're all going to be
millionaires whatever i talk about
really
some of the hard the hard truths
regarding um crypto and bitcoin like a
lot of people like oh my god bitcoin is
completely the future
and it is to an extent but at the same
time too if you can't get the middle
class or the poor to pick up and start
using bitcoin is it really
is it just going to be for the rich
people so really my goal is to
obviously continue to grow but like if i
had if i was a perfect world i would
want to become
very very rich and i would want to
continue to do the charity work that i'm
doing
and to educate people and just to kind
of help my local community
like even though i just moved out of my
neighborhood i sold the house um i still
go in i box at the same boxing gym
and i would like to do some more like
charitable stuff um talking to the kids
about crypto and why it's so important
and kind of just getting them excited
like i'll give kids the boxing
gym bitcoin and you know just to kind of
get them started and whatnot
so what do you say to them what do you
say how do you like
hey kids have you had a bitcoin like how
does it go like
kids you know you ready like what do you
do so
it kind of it really depends and this is
the tactic that i used to
use when i worked in healthcare is you
can't just walk up to somebody like oh
my god buy bitcoin
because number one you sound like an
idiot no one no one knows what bitcoin
is it's really unrealistic you see
people posting about it all the time on
twitter but it's like really just shut
up because that's not that's not
realistic maybe you guys are talking to
rich people maybe you guys are talking
to people
with strong tech backgrounds that know
how this stuff works but when you're
talking about people that come from poor
and lower
class neighborhoods you can't just kind
of be like oh you need to invest your
money in bitcoin you talk to them you
get to know who they are you build a
relationship with them and then you find
out how it can improve their quality of
life
me particularly at my boxing gym i've
got a lot of people that have family
that live in mexico
sending bitcoin or sending
cryptocurrency to mexico is going to be
a lot cheaper and a lot better for them
than using western union
so there's there's that argument but it
really depends who the person is
and you can't just start pitching this
stuff you're going to sound like an like
a mlm marketer
you have to really find out more about
the person and get to know them you have
to build
trust and build honesty there because if
you're just talking out the side of your
neck you're going to sound like an idiot
and it's kind of counterproductive to
what we're supposed to be doing in the
space
yeah it is counterproductive because you
know if anybody comes up to you
particularly when it's about finances
and somebody's sort of telling you what
to do with your money you know
people will always think that there's an
ulterior motive and really that
there's absolutely not because you know
if you know some random person let's
just call them like joe blogs or
whatever i don't know if that's like a
british sort of
name that we use i don't know i said you
just go up to him you say hey you know
you need to buy bitcoin it's really
going to add no value to my life so
obviously it doesn't make a difference
um so yeah when you talk about finances
it is something you have to be really
touchy about with other people
well also too when you're going into
like the hood or when you're going into
a poor neighborhood and you're like oh
you need to invest your money in this
these people don't have 401ks
they don't care about investing their
money they don't care about making their
money work for them they don't know most
of them are not even financially
illiterate
and that's just because their families
and they they're so focused on just
paying their bills and eating and taking
care of their families they don't care
about anything else
but if you can maybe gift them bitcoin
or maybe kind of talk to them on how it
could improve their quality life and
kind of talk to them about personal
finance
and explain why a credit card is a bad
idea don't buy this brand new car you
don't want to be in debt
and talk to them about accumulating
wealth or how you get out of debt that's
kind of how you can change their life
but just kind of showing them something
that they're really not going to
understand because let's face it bitcoin
is not easy to understand you walk up to
a random person
if you're to go on the street right now
and talk to 10 people i bet you
maybe one of them could tell you how
bitcoin works if if you're lucky or what
blockchain technology is a lot of people
don't know what that is and you don't
want to push that
on somebody when you first meet them
they're going to think you're crazy
person
yeah for sure do you think people need
to know how it works you know depending
on what degree
you're participating in this so like you
and i obviously need to know how it
works
but the people at your gym do they need
to know how it works or do they just
sort of need to know what it can do for
them in a great way
it depends and that all that goes with
building a relationship and building a
rapport with somebody because let's say
for example i have one kid
that he just wants to help his mom be
able to send money back home to mexico
that's fantastic so we really don't need
to get too involved with blockchain
technology but we do want to let them
know that it's immutable that the
transaction cannot be reversed
you know it's going to get there faster
the fees are going to be less but when
we're talking to another person
that is interested in maybe you know
working in tech
or working in stem then we really want
to hit hard on that blockchain
technology and how cool it is and about
the coding and whatnot and then from
there because i'm not
not a big tech person i would link them
with somebody that i knew or i would
reach out to somebody i know as a mentor
and link them that way yeah i'm
absolutely with you i kind of want to
move on a little bit uh and talk about
your journey into crypto though because
i know
that you did experience a lot of
negativity um particularly because you
do talk about a lot of different
projects and you might get some hate
from like
different communities whether it's the
bitcoin maximalism community or whatever
it is
so why why do you think that happened
and
and also more importantly how do you
deal with that because
i think could be wrong i do think crypto
twitter
maybe maybe make up twitter first maybe
like the whole like makeup and beauty
and all that might be the most toxic
twitter
but then twitter might come in second so
how do you deal with all of that
so people got mad at me because i was
very honest and i disclosed my
partnerships i comply with all of the
sec laws i think it's the sec law of
1944 i disclosed the nature of the scope
and the amount that i was paid i've
always done that
pay my taxes on any type of sponsored
work i do or any clients that i have
people didn't like that and that's fine
they don't have to like it but the funny
part about that is
a lot of people that trust me they
either had paid groups they're still in
ref links now
and they have their own marketing
companies so it kind of tells me i was
doing something right and they were just
kind of too beta cuck to
to just whatever and a lot of people are
kind of hopping on that bag bandwagon of
let's hate and whatever
because it's very common with twitter
especially with crypto twitter is if
there's one person that's getting
a lot of a lot of people will pile
on and they do that because they want to
try to run you out and to push you out
but i'm not going anywhere and i at the
same time too like
i don't even at this point there's some
people that are just going to always
dislike me and that's fine
and i respect i can respect i don't get
it though
i'm not i'm not getting it i'm not i
don't know it's
because because you disclose your
partnerships and how much money you're
making surely that's actually fantastic
no i think it is but you know
everybody's entitled to their opinion
and i get it
but the same thing is if you're gonna
get mad at somebody for something make
sure that your side of the gym is clean
and that you're doing you're doing
things they're ethical and
you know for a while i was like one of
the only girls that was out there
posting stuff and talking about stuff
and i don't to be honest like i'm not
exactly sure
the exact reasons why and that's fine
like you don't have to like me i'm
literally not for everybody
and that's fine but at the same but at
the same time too like you're not gonna
you're not you're going to trash me
online but you're not going to say it to
my face i think i've met
um i've met quite a few people that
didn't like me they've came up to me
they've apologized to me
saying whatever and i just guess what i
do have to say for people that are being
jerks online
you don't understand what somebody's
going through in their personal or their
home life and if you just don't if you
don't like someone just block them
like i just i don't get that type of
mentality that bully mentality i hate
bullies i really really do
yeah i'm taking with you i i can't under
i mean think that like we're all human
things obviously frustrate us
online we see things we don't agree with
we think we see things when like god
that person is such a shill or whatever
it is you know you can't help but get
frustrated
but i don't understand and with you
people that have to then feel the need
to express that just mute them block
them
like i was i tweeted the other day i've
never i never put a thumbs down on a
youtube video in my life like i just
don't really care
isn't it just kind of to me it's kind of
ridiculous like you would really go out
of your way to harass somebody online
like is your personal life that pathetic
like
i just to me i don't get it like i'm not
gonna go out of my way to do anything
negative for somebody like if i don't
like you we're just not gonna eat
together at the same table
that's it and i'm gonna move on like i
personally i could care less
because it's not really helping me to to
sit and whatever but there's also a very
popular popular marketing tactic on
crypto twitter is the attacking of
people and to get into gang up
what crypto twitter will do they will
see one person that's getting ganged up
or people are making fun of
and they'll pile on because they think
it's cool and it's that sheep mentality
it's that herd mentality
you'll see this in other industries as
well but it's especially toxic with
crypto
and that's totally fine but really it's
kind
to me it's just kind it's literally
ridiculous because i get these same
people that they pop in my dms later and
they ask me for something and they want
me to do something yeah
all the all the time and i'm just like
you sat here you took this idea from me
you trash me online and you want to be
cool with me that's fine we could be
cool but we're not eating together at
the same table it's not going to happen
you're not getting inside my network
and that's it oh my god i'm totally with
you i don't i don't know how people have
the audacity to do that so
a couple of months ago you know i was
posting tick tocks and i got a lot of
hate for i was the first one to do tick
tocks basically and now everyone does
them or whatever but
i was the first one today i got a lot of
hate for it and the very people
that were hating me for it pop up in my
dms asking to work with me and i'm just
like
i don't know i don't i don't want to i'm
good you know
yeah it's it's like that and i mean
there is some stuff that is super cringy
that you will see
um that's just like absolutely
ridiculous and
i'm just like you guys are really really
ridiculous but at the same time too i
just mute because i don't really care
just taking energy away from me like
being a mom or doing what i need to do
and if somebody doesn't like me that's
fine but i guarantee you will attend one
of my events and
we'll have a good time we'll have a beer
together i love that i like that
so a couple more questions for you so we
spoke about
a lot of different um sponsorships that
you have so you must obviously get a lot
of different projects coming to you
and some projects are authentic some not
so authentic
so firstly how do you sort of decide
whether you want to work with those
projects
particularly actually d5 projects um you
know there's a lot coming out right now
and you know there's a lot of rug pulls
so how do we
how do you know whether you want to work
with them or not
so generally what i do is i will set
i'll sometimes i'll set up calls with
the teams depending on what it what it
is
a lot of times i don't respond to
anybody like if you if you dm me and you
want to work with me
i will probably not answer i have my
email address set up there for a reason
and the people that are actually able to
follow directions and email me and like
give me
you know reasons why they're excited
about their project what their project
does
show me that it has lock liquidity show
me the github code
that all that stuff is fine and what i
do is i ask for the code and i ask what
you know different questions and then
the tech stuff i will forward to friends
of mine that work in the space that are
you know
tech savvy in the big okay this looks a
little shady here this was copied and
pasted this you know just different
things like that
and then i'll make my decision that way
one of the things though
it's hard for me is that i like to i
like to sit down and talk to a lot of
different people in the space
and it makes it hard because there's
there is so many scams but the way
i've done i want to say over 140
interviews in crypto
with different projects and the way i
learn is sitting down and talking to
people or reviewing a project
but like now i know i do have people
that i do reach out to i'm like hey is
this like a scam or then i'll do my
little investigation too especially with
the non-team members
and i'll see if they had worked on any
other projects that which was a scam or
not
and you know rug rug polls are always
going to happen
but what a lot of people do need to
understand is we are essentially in a
free market you guys are screaming and
crying that you want a free market you
want to get rich you want
moon moon lambo or whatever the heck
it's really on you to do your own
research of the project as well and like
if you see something that's wrong be
like hey wendy this is wrong whatever
like there's there's two projects that i
covered um
in the last six months that i that ended
up not being legit
projects i had invested in them myself
so i lost money too
and i pulled those videos down and i
said i apologize to my audience to my
community
and that at this time in crypto that's
just what a lot of people are
gonna have to do because we can't really
we can't really
it's really hard to see what is a scam
and what's not like we have that one
company cred that
raised i think like 28 million dollars
in an ico that was supposed to be like a
like a lending platform and apparently
they went bankrupt or something happened
and they turned out to be a scam but a
lot of people use this project and they
thought it was legit
but apparently they're not but then we
even have legitimate projects like big
exchanges
that do shady stuff in the background
and people call them scams too
so it's the definition of scam is very
very hard to define in crypto because
generally if you're not making money in
crypto on a certain project it's a scam
yeah absolutely i think scam has a whole
new meaning um
when you when you enter crypto um i want
to change the subject a little bit
actually um
really random question for you um but i
have it written down and i just kind of
want to ask it so
i just want to know who inspires you
who inspires me um honestly i have to
say
to say myself and probably
probably my great aunt and the reason
why my great aunt was the most
inspirational person for me is number
one i don't like to look to
celebrities for inspiration because
they're not regular people
they are regular people but they're not
things are as you know them
not as you know them a lot of people
online their personas like what you see
with me is what you get but a lot of
people online they have these personas
that are just not
like they're not accurate they're not
real especially you see a lot of these
ig models and i'm not shaming them i'm
not saying like this is a bad what
they're doing
but the light but the the way that
they're portraying themselves that's not
really who they are how their families
are like
my house is messy i've got a
four-year-old daughter there's toys in
my living room there's toys in my dining
room there's toys in my bedroom there's
toys in my office there's toys in her
room
like my my stuff is not perfect but my
great aunt was so inspirational for me
is because
she was a silent feminist so when i talk
about a silent feminist
she back in back in the 40s
her her mother and her father they
brought her my grandma over here from
sicily they're first generation
immigrants
they were born in the united states
and she she worked in a sweatshop with
my grandma
and then she was able to get a job at
chemical bank in brooklyn i want to say
wall street new york and she started
sweeping floors and she worked her way
up to a teller and then worked her way
up
in the court on the corporate ladder and
she was able to travel when she wanted
to she made very very good money but
because she was a woman she was not able
to get title of like a ceo or president
or any of these other high-level
corporate jobs because she was a woman
but in the background she did a lot of
training for these guys that
ended up doing really well and being
successful um
and she never complained about her life
she never complained about how hard it
was she never complained about
immigrating she never complained about
anything she just worked really hard she
lived life on her terms
and she was always she always cared for
other people's children like
in brooklyn there's lots of um like
apartment buildings
and generally what the sicilian
americans would do you would go move
into apartment building with your other
family members so everybody was right
there
she'd always take like local kids they
would come in and she would like have
not tea parties but she would serve them
like coffee and cake or make them
sandwiches
just stuff like that so she was always
she was a very catholic woman
and she gave back to her community and
lived life on her terms
i like that and um that me that means
silent feminists i've never heard that
term before
i like to use the term silent feminist
because obviously back in those times in
the 40s and 50s women
they went to they went to high school
they got married and they had kids they
didn't work
my aunt did the opposite she went to
work she refused to get married because
the man that she fell in love with was a
doctor he was divorced
and in the catholic religion back then
you didn't marry somebody who was
divorced
and she just never found anybody else
that she was interested in she could
have gotten married she was very very
pretty she could have gotten married to
you know someone at the bank someone
making a lot of money um she traveled
the world
most women did not travel the world back
then she traveled to places like haiti
um and just you know different parts of
south america
but she to me she was a pioneer for
women's rights without having to go out
and be
messy like we see a lot of these other
people she just she
she put her she put her livelihood um
out on the line and
did did really great things but without
saying hey i'm a feminist and i'm
fighting for women's right she just went
and she actually did it and to me that's
a silent feminist and that's the type of
woman that i aspire to be
yeah that's a really interesting story
um i was watching i watched a lot of
movies from
that era and i see there's always sort
of that woman i guess now you could call
her that silent feminist
who you know is sort of going against
the grain and she's not being a
secretary but she's being something else
and i often wonder if i was during those
times
what would i be like or what would i do
just because right now
i'd say i'm quite an ambitious person i
don't really like labels i'm not really
interested in any gender rubbish i'm
just me and i just do what i want
whatever i feel
um but my grandma was a secretary
um and maybe her mother didn't even work
so that's interesting that you actually
have somebody in your family
who if a woman that actually did go
against the grain so you could sort of
imagine what you had been like back then
i guess oh yeah she was very she was
very very sassy and there was a story
that she told me like because my grandma
was very timid and my grandma
my grandma used to work in different
sweatshops and she was actually a
seamstress for
some european princess or whatever but
she ended up getting me
she ended up getting married um to my
grandpa i had kids was a stay-at-home
mom
but my aunt i guess i had gotten a
fistfight in the middle of the street
because my aunt wanted to ditch school
to go see frank sinatra and my grandma
was like no no we can't do that so they
got like this little like girl fight or
whatever
because she was very like my aunt wanted
to always go out and do stuff but
um she is probably my my somebody that i
look up to for inspiration because she
was just always so selfless like she
took me and my mom my two sisters into
her house in california
um me and it was a two-bedroom townhome
and me and my mom my two sisters we
lived in a bedroom
from when i was 11 to 18. and that was
my life um for
quite some time wow
speaking of inspiration and things which
sort of keep you going and motivated and
things like that
you are really into your boxing your
mma which is super cool because i'm
super into
weightlifting so i feel like there's
like a synergy there so talk to me
about that how did you get into it
because surely your first time going
you're probably the only woman which is
probably the same experience you had
going into crypto you were the only
woman or whatever so
how did you how did you get into that so
i actually learned to box when i was 16
so i was always very outspoken and i
started having issues with some of the
girls at school they were being very
nasty to me because um they're they're
running around doing some bs and i
called them out on it
um so i needed to learn to kind of
defend myself
so a friend kind of taught me a couple
moves and then i just kept it up i
remember working at a drug store
i saved up enough money to buy a 50 50
pound
bag and i would just train i would took
the stuff that he taught me
and i would train an hour in the morning
hour and night from 16 to 18.
and not only did it teach me confidence
but it really just kind of taught me
that i am strong i am powerful and i am
in control of my life so it was
something that was good to help then i
started
you know just being kind of a hot mess
so i stopped doing that
um but then you know this year's been
really good for me and my family
and with all this copic thing happening
i was like i need to do something for
myself
to keep me mentally stable i've gone to
different therapists i've been on
medication before i do struggle with
mental health issues
and i've been to so many therapists and
psychiatrists none of that to me none of
that stuff works it's complete
it it just it doesn't work because
you're just sitting there and you're
having somebody co-sign your i
don't want anybody to co-sign my
i want to get give me solutions
give me help um so but that's
that's kind of my outlet with boxing but
the gym that i go to it's actually run
by a woman her name is miss nita
and she is a family therapist and she
helps
the type of work she does i support that
because she helps
she works very closely with cv cps which
is child child protective services
she helps kids and families that are
dealing with domestic abuse
all different types of crazy stuff it's
not your typical like oh my god
i need to see a therapist because i'm so
sad because like oh my god i've got
these problems
it's like some real stuff it's like i
have like you've got an abusive parent
there's a drinking problem
your people the kids are getting hurt
there's like some real serious
stuff that's there maybe a parent passed
away but she opened this gym
to um help kids in our neighborhood
in my old neighborhood now that are
going through some serious stuff and to
let them know they matter and they're
important and
any type of martial arts or physical
activity is a great way to
combat mental illness um so the first
time i went in there was only white girl
in there and that's kind of been the
story for me for a little bit because
the people i used to hang out with in
the areas that i used to live in and
whatnot
so i was a little bit nervous like oh my
god are they gonna accept me because
there is
there is you know that type of stuff if
you go into a neighborhood and you know
you don't look like them they're to look
at you sideways and you actually have to
earn your keep the same thing with
crypto when you're new brand new to
crypto
people are just not going to support you
you have to earn your keep you have to
prove your worth so i'm very familiar
with that type of stuff
with some of the people i used to run
with but i kept coming in they saw that
i could actually you know move and work
and so i'm i'm close with everybody
that's in there now and
it's just i'm very thankful that i can
actually afford to train professionally
for the first time in my life like i was
very poor growing up i didn't have
access to a lot of stuff because my mom
didn't have the money
um but now i'm able to kind of pay for
things and live a better quality of life
i think you know it's so true that
doing physical exercise which actually
challenges you
is just so insanely amazing for your
mental health and i feel like it's just
not something that
we talk about enough i think i mean
correct me if i'm wrong it's just
something that i've noticed because i've
spent a little just a little bit of time
this day it's not a lot but
there's this push just to sort of get
kids on medication just sort of
straight away before we sort of deal
with what it is first and it's the same
in in the uk but i believe it's just
more in the us
and we don't sort of stop and say well
hang on you know have you people think
you're ridiculous when you say go for a
run we don't really mean it like that
but
i mean for me i do a lot of
weightlifting
and the reason i do it it isn't really
for the physical reasons i mean that's
just great but i do it literally because
it just clears my mind like
it's absolute meditation it's so
peaceful
um and it really makes you feel strong
so say i go in the morning
i really feel like i can tackle anything
the rest of the day
um it's a bit like when people say the
best gift you can give yourself is to
make your bed in the morning
because once your bed's made it's like
oh i've done one task today like
tick you know so you can do plenty of
other tasks the rest of the day
is that low is that low talking yeah do
you want us i don't want you i don't
want people to see your face but do you
want to say hi
okay hi hi
how are you doing she she we'll talk
about the christmas list in a little bit
give me a couple minutes okay
i that is so amazing yeah this
cat here you can have that cathy hannah
oh we're gonna call santa later today
okay i'm
missing this one okay well i really need
it because my
other one is gone forever okay
oh my gosh you've got some crazy
christmas plans coming up then you've
got it she's got a big list for you
doesn't she
she does mommy listen mommy mommy's
doing work why don't
oh and she's going to slam the door oh
no she's not going to stand there
um so medication is for i i kind of lost
train of
train of thought um but in the united
states a lot of times they push
medication
and well most of the times i was on
medication for a long period of time the
only reason why i stopped is because i
decided to get pregnant and have a child
um throughout my pregnancy i really i
like prepared for it i trained i trained
extra hard i made sure i was under
like a certain weight because i knew i
was gonna gain weight um i completely
got off all my medication for a year
um so i can have have a healthy baby i
breastfed her exclusively for a year
but medication really is pushed um as a
as a coping mechanism and it shouldn't
be that way and i feel like it's because
our generation is very very soft
everybody's used to winning trophies
everybody's used to
um a lot of people aren't used to strife
and you see that with a lot of people in
cryptos you get all these people in
these white ivory towers that
have these ideas and thoughts about
stuff and it's not really reality
but i think that if you can get up some
days i don't feel like making my bed but
i will do 20 push-ups
so if you can get up yeah wait i'm with
you sometimes i don't feel like making
my bed but i i do lift instead so i'm
just like whatever
you got to do what you got to do but
honestly like i'll do 20 jump squats or
i'll do like 20 push-ups and that just
really kind of helps me
to feel better about whatever it is
and then it kind of gets your mind off
some of the really bad stuff that's
happening or maybe the stuff that you
have isn't even that bad but you're just
sitting there focusing on it maybe just
do breathing or yoga
um but def medication should not be
first route
i think you should try to do other
things first that's just me though but
if you feel like you need to be on
medication
go see a health professional you do what
works for you i'm totally with you
okay so just for the last sort of
section of this i do want to talk about
the markets
because bitcoin has been going crazy
let's have a look where the price is at
okay still still 16 000. that's exciting
so
i gotta get you back up on the screen
there you are okay so what are your
thoughts
what is going on i want to talk to you
actually about 2.0 because obviously we
have that announcement we're expecting
it soon so
how do you think that's going to affect
the price um what are you expecting
what sort of trades do you have lined up
and also
since the announcement it has of course
gone up over four hundred dollars
what is it 478 or 80 i think it went too
so give me your thoughts
so as far with is bitcoin yes we are at
a very very amazing price point at like
16 000
but a great indicator that you can use
is the money flow index or money flow
indicator and it kind of lets you know
if money is entering the market or not
if there's no money going into the
market price is not going to pump
um as far as us breaking all-time high
with bitcoin i think it is definitely
possible
but i'm also expecting like a 30
pullback that's going to happen because
if you look at the price and you look at
historical events that have happened in
the past as far as just price
we do get those volatile pullbacks and
that's fine i'm in a long position i've
been in a long since about 11
400 i was in and out at 10 a 10-5
and so i just keep moving my stop up and
just keep letting it right
um with ethereum 2.0 that is a whole
different ball game and i might not be
the correct person to answer
um because i'm not super tech savvy i
just know that
ethereum is going to have to sustain
because if ethereum doesn't sustain
all the coins that were built on
top of it are going to die
and that's the truth as f as far as 2.0
i don't know too much about it i have
saved up enough
enough eath to run one of those nodes or
whatever it is i guess
so i will be doing that with help from
friends because i'm not to be trusted to
set that up myself
um i think that is bullish for eth long
term however
um just because we have all these things
that are very exciting we're seeing all
these millionaires i know a lot of
people are like oh my god this person
bought so much bitcoin invested millions
of dollars
but really that wasn't why bitcoin was
created it was created for the regular
person it came out of strife of 2008
um so i do think that the price is going
to go up with both assets but
please be very careful when you guys are
trading this stuff if you guys are
interested in getting into alts please
make sure to understand what bitcoin is
doing maybe check the bitcoin dominance
chart to see
if we break over that 70 um that 70 area
you're also going to get completely
wrecked
um what you want to look for is nice
consolidations per nice consolidation
periods with bitcoin when you get those
nice consolidation periods your alts
will generally do well
but make sure you practice very very
strict risk management with that
and for eth 2.0 again i think it's
a good thing i think it's very bullish
but
at the same time i'm also very cautious
and i don't want a big i don't want to
be one of those people like oh my god a
bitcoin is going to go to a million
dollars
because what happens if it doesn't
mm-hmm
then you can have loads of people coming
to you screaming yeah so i just want to
be kind of like
i always want to kind of be honest in my
predictions i do think that we will
surpass all-time high of 20
000 eventually it is going to take time
um i do think once bitcoin reaches a
very very high amount that it will be
less volatile and more people will be
excited
potentially excited about it um but we
also have a lot of other projects
that um are kind of that do
do things differently than bitcoin
bitcoin will always be around it will be
an amazing store of value but just be
very
careful when you're investing and
whatnot and you know don't necessarily
listen to what other people are saying
do what works for you
do it works for your portfolio do it
works for your family and stick to your
trading plan or your investing plan
and then just finally then because you
did sort of mention other projects and
whatever so you're i mean i know you
talk about many different projects so
this this question might seem sort of
off but
in terms of you and how you perceive
crypto
do you sort of think it's bitcoin only
or do you sort of
think you know there are a lot of other
projects doing incredible things which
will revolutionize the way that we do
finance i mean even d5 for example do
you think there's actually something
there like
let's say 20 years down the line will
people really be taking out mortgages i
know you can now and some people do but
like seriously
you know are you going to be taking out
mortgages in 20 years on the blockchain
i think 100 i think that um once we get
less of a gray area
um with regulation regulation is
important there's a lot of like f
regulation i don't want regulation or i
don't want regulation
we need we kind of need to coexist
because the governments and all these
different countries they're not going to
let you guys do what you want to do
like we're seeing what's happening in
nigeria they're basically
closing bank accounts over there to
people that don't um express the same
views as them and that kind of stuff
could happen in the united states too it
can happen anywhere look at stuff that's
going on with china
um so with bitcoin i do think that
bitcoin will always be
um queen b but i think there will be
other projects as well that are gonna
kind of solve some of these solutions
um just because bitcoin does have a lot
of scaling issues
bitcoin will always be my first love but
i do think there will be other projects
in the space that do really really great
stuff we've got healthcare industries
we've got the dfi industry
um the purpose of d5 this aspect of d5
that makes me most excited
is knowing that there will be there will
be applications that will allow
people um from incomes like myself and
grew up the way i did that will have be
able to have access
for money for mortgages for maybe even
ten thousand dollars to start a small
business in the united states you can't
go into your bank
and take a ten thousand dollar loan out
for a small business they won't give it
to you
at all but you can buy a car that
depreciates right when it comes off the
lot they'll give you the loan for that
but they won't let you
they won't actually invest in your
business um
so defy is a great application for that
um but i do think that we do need
altcoins as well in the space because
without competition people get lazy and
if there's all coins that are competing
for bitcoin spot
bitcoin developers and people that are
very bullish on bitcoin they're going to
continue to
um to grow so with all of that in mind
what are your final thoughts that you
want to leave the show
on i'll make you full screen for the
drum for the dramatic the dramatic with
my
with my crinkled curtain um all that i
want to say
is i i love bitcoin i think bitcoin is
fantastic and i'm very happy and
thankful and grateful to be in crypto
um but don't lose sight of what's really
important folks don't lose sight of your
personal freedoms don't lose sight of
your families don't lose sight of who
you were um before getting into crypto
and some of the dreams and aspirations
that you have um continue to grow make
money but don't forget to give back when
you can and when i'm talking about
giving back i'm not saying give money to
people
if you can be of service to your local
communities and help people
maybe even just smile at people um and
just
that's really all i want to say and um
thank you for having me on the show it
was a great time and
just be a nice person especially with
times as as tough as they are
totally agree with you um smile more
why not and i i'm with you i think you
know those who those who aren't kind be
suspicious of them because it costs
nothing
so wendy i will say i will say be
also be very suspicious of people that
are overly kind because sometimes they
don't have
sometimes they don't have good motives
and there's people that are legitimately
psychotic out there and i'm just i'm
saying that from personal experience so
yeah no i'm with you wendy i want to
thank you so much it's been such a
pleasure i've been so excited to chat to
you and just
learn more about you i want to thank
iconplus for powering this block 5
sponsoring it coinflip for sponsoring it
and zelepe who are my new sponsors so
guys don't forget to tune in next week
thursday 12 est bye
[Applause]
[Music]